something that's deceivingly simple but
it's not those are my favorite recipes
that it looks like there's only three or
four components on a plate but it's it's
made with a lot of technique and you can
taste it and you can see it and that to
me is a great recipe where I mean you
know that that's a pretty broad
statement but there's many dishes that
I'm envious of that other chefs make
that I'm like oh my god that's genius
that's so delicious and no one can do it
because that requires such a high level
of skill and to me that's a great recipe
because at the same time it's easy to do
but there's a barrier to accomplishing
it because of the technique level in
that and the skill level and those are
ones I appreciate the most so many
things what Wiley makes at wd-50 I just
get so mad at sometimes he's a good
friend whip they're so delicious but I'm
just like man he's so smart and I just
it boggles my mind because at the end of
the day it looks complicated but it's
not you know it's it's an understanding
food and food theory and building upon
flavor profiles chef Keller or - you
know people are just like wow that's
really delicious or you know simple like
the salmon cornet is like the greatest
amuse-bouche of all time because it's so
simple it's it's and at that that flavor
combination has been around for years
but not packaged that way and not
executed at the high level and it could
just be like pasta from Andrew
Carmellini
you know or getting fish slice from
sefie chef Yasuda at sushi us you know
it's like stuff that has a lot of
technique it looks simple slicing fish
but it's not that simple those are the
things that get me excited I say this
because one of our sous chefs said this
is like the the this like sort of the
signature sort of the Momofuku dish and
I I think it was simple like just cherry
tomatoes on tofu shiso and like a little
sesame soy vinaigrette not that that
it's difficult to
but it took us a long time to figure
that one out it's out it's basically our
take on a salad caprese a and you know
we have all these market tomatoes in
orders like what are we gonna do we're
just looking literally looking at them
on the on the table like just like okay
we're sort of an Asian restaurant how
the hell are we gonna serve these and we
just stared at for good our drinking a
beer in and it was just like all right
no wouldn't thought of anything and we'd
come home and I thought about it some
more and we're like okay let's peel the
grape tomatoes and the cherry tomatoes
because I don't necessarily like the
texture on a cherry tomato so it's nice
and beautiful too so you quickly brought
blanch it and we'll make beautiful
little cylinders of tofu and we'll
gently put it on and make a nice shift
out of Bay of shiso so it looks like
basil you know the whole thing looks
like mozzarella and tomatoes and basil
but the the flavor profile is completely
different and it couldn't be more simple
and we like that dish